This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. After the revolution in Cuba, the young Fidel Castro hired an official photographer by the name of Alberto Cora to chronicle his new life as a national leader. Cora followed Castro and Che Guevara, taking pictures of them as they met world leaders, went fishing, faced off in chess. He even took that iconic image of Che, the one that's on millions of t-shirts.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。古巴革命后，年轻的菲德尔·卡斯特罗聘请了一位名叫阿尔贝托·科尔达的官方摄影师，来记录他作为国家领导人的新生活。科尔达跟随卡斯特罗和切·格瓦拉，拍摄了他们会见世界领导人、钓鱼、下棋的照片。他还拍下了那张标志性的切·格瓦拉照片，就是印在数百万件T恤上的那张。
That's common, I'd trouble me. But my favorite images that Corda captured are of Che and Fidel playing golf. It was January 3rd, 1961, two years after the revolution. When Che suggested they go play around. You know, Figueroen said, well, you know, I don't play golf, and Che did play golf. He was actually pretty good. And he'd been a caddy back in Chile.
这很常见，我倒觉得没什么。但我最喜欢科尔达拍摄的切和菲德尔打高尔夫球的照片。那是1961年1月3日，革命两年后。当切建议他们去打一场球时，你知道，菲德尔说，嗯，你知道，我不会打高尔夫，而切会打。他其实打得相当不错。他在智利时还当过球童。
Helping us tell this story is John Lumis. I'm John Lumis. I'm an architect and an architectural historian. So Che and Fidel drove out to what was the Ritzios most elite country club in Havana. All the members of the club, they practically have all left the country, but still here's this amazing place. The people who work here are still keeping everything clean and neat and taking care of it. And Che and Fidel romp around the bucolic green acres. In full military khaki and combat boots. Chase still wearing that beret.
帮助我们讲述这个故事的是约翰·卢米斯。我是约翰·卢米斯。我是一名建筑师和建筑历史学家。切和菲德尔开车去了哈瓦那最精英的乡村俱乐部。俱乐部的所有成员几乎都离开了这个国家，但这个令人惊叹的地方依然存在。在这里工作的人们仍然保持着一切整洁，并照料着这里。切和菲德尔在田园诗般的绿色草地上嬉戏。他们穿着全套军用卡其布制服和作战靴。切还戴着那顶贝雷帽。
And Castro is choking up on a golf club as if he's never seen someone use a golf club before. They're just putting around and grinning while Alberto Corda snapped publicity shots of them. And you know you look at the photographs and they're like school boys just having fun and this was a lark and everybody thought this was you you know, a real, a real hoot. And the photos are actually beautiful because Corda is an incredible photographer, but also because the landscape is breathtaking. There's a river running through all these gently undulating, perfectly manicured hills bordered by this thick, lush forest of tropical plants.
卡斯特罗握着高尔夫球杆的样子，就好像他从没见过别人用球杆一样。他们只是在果岭上推杆，咧着嘴笑，而阿尔贝托·科尔达则在一旁为他们拍摄宣传照。你看这些照片，他们就像玩耍的男学生，这只是一场恶作剧，每个人都觉得这真是太有趣了。这些照片实际上很美，因为科尔达是一位出色的摄影师，也因为这里的风景令人叹为观止。一条河流穿过这些起伏平缓、修剪整齐的山丘，周围环绕着茂密的热带植物森林。
It's kind of magical. Che Inf Fidel were captivated by this place, and they looked around and wondered, what should we do with this? You know, this is a wonderful resource. It wasn't going to stay a golf course, that was for sure. And some say it was Fidel's idea, other say it was Che's, but one of them turned to the other and explained his vision for the property.
这简直太神奇了。切和菲德尔被这个地方迷住了，他们环顾四周，心想，我们该拿它怎么办？你知道，这是一种极好的资源。可以肯定的是，它不会再是一个高尔夫球场了。有人说是菲德尔的主意，也有人说是切的主意，但其中一人转向另一人，阐述了他对这片土地的愿景。
There, they would build an art school. An international school for the arts that would draw students from all over the third world and bring them to Cuba and give them a first-class art education and all the art disciplines of free of charge. And a beautiful vision for a beautiful landscape required a beautiful building. Che and Fidel decided they wanted to build the most gorgeous art schools in the world, something fitting with the newness and excitement of the fresh revolution. Castro was recommended the young Cuban architect Ricardo Poro,
在那里，他们要建立一所艺术学校。一所国际艺术学校，将吸引来自整个第三世界的学生来到古巴，并免费提供一流的艺术教育和所有艺术学科的培训。美丽的风景需要美丽的建筑来匹配。切和菲德尔决定建造世界上最华丽的艺术学校，以契合新革命带来的新鲜感和兴奋感。卡斯特罗推荐了年轻的古巴建筑师里卡多·波罗，
and he knew that Ricardo was very, had very much supported the revolution, had risked his own life. By housing rebels, Poro had never picked up a gun or anything. And in addition to his commitment to the revolution, he was also really talented. So he seemed like the obvious person to choose. Poro was told that if he wanted to design the schools, he would have to do it almost immediately. You have to end the project in two months to begin the construction, I say, but it's impossible. This is footage of Ricardo Poro in 2004. Poro passed away in 2014. Poro was told that's it, two months for the designs. You take it or you leave it. And I remember I asked and I said, well, so Ricardo, what
他知道里卡多非常支持革命，甚至冒着生命危险收留叛军。波罗从未拿过枪之类的东西。除了对革命的承诺，他确实非常有才华。所以他似乎是显而易见的人选。波罗被告知，如果他想设计这些学校，他必须立即行动。我说，必须在两个月内完成项目以开始施工，但这不可能。这是2004年里卡多·波罗的录像。波罗于2014年去世。波罗被告知就是这样，两个月时间完成设计。要么接受，要么放弃。我记得我问过，我说，好吧，那么里卡多，什么
you said, and he says, well, John, you're an architect, you know? You say, I take it! I take it! Now the art school wasn't just one school. It was imagined as an entire campus with five separate schools for five distinct disciplines. ballet, modern dance, visual arts, music, and theater. Ricardo Poro was going to need some help. He recruited two architect friends, two Italians, Fitorio Garati and Roberto Gautardi.
你说，他说，嗯，约翰，你是建筑师，你知道吗？你说，我接受！我接受！现在，这所艺术学校不仅仅是一所学校。它被设想为一个完整的校园，拥有五个独立的学院，分别对应五个不同的学科：芭蕾舞、现代舞、视觉艺术、音乐和戏剧。里卡多·波罗需要一些帮助。他招募了两位建筑师朋友，两位意大利人，维托里奥·加拉蒂和罗伯托·高塔迪。
Oh, and in addition to the time crunch, there was the embargo. Already with the embargo, importing concrete and rebar was very expensive. They had to use what they had. The three architects decided to build with locally made brick and terracotta tiles. And with these tiles, they decided to make schools comprised of cattle and vaults. A cattle and vault is essentially a dome made of layered tiles. And it's called a cattle and vault because it's predominantly used in Catalonia, especially Barcelona.
哦，除了时间紧迫之外，还有禁运问题。由于禁运，进口水泥和钢筋非常昂贵。他们必须利用现有的材料。三位建筑师决定用当地制造的砖块和赤陶瓦来建造。利用这些瓦片，他们决定建造由加泰罗尼亚拱顶组成的学校。加泰罗尼亚拱顶本质上是由分层瓦片制成的圆顶。之所以叫加泰罗尼亚拱顶，是因为它主要用于加泰罗尼亚，尤其是巴塞罗那。
It was adopted particularly by Gaudi to do these very organic forms. And so, with the unifying element of brick and unified style of Catalan Vault, the three architects began to erect their separate designs around the edges of the golf course. Okay, I'm going to throw journalistic impartiality to the wind here. These buildings are so beautiful. Each uses the vault in a completely different way. And they all roll over the landscape of the golf course and mix with the plants and the palm trees,
它特别被高迪采用，用来制作这些非常有机的形式。因此，以砖块为统一元素，以加泰罗尼亚拱顶为统一风格，三位建筑师开始在高尔夫球场的边缘竖起他们各自的设计。好吧，我要抛开新闻公正性了。这些建筑太美了。每一座都以完全不同的方式使用了拱顶。它们在球场的景观上起伏，与植物和棕榈树融为一体，
and they wind, and they bend, and they unfurl into these plazas and courtyards. And their curving rooftops with all those vaults make them look alive, like they're dancing. And each school has a clear story to tell, with very intentional symbolism. But Poro's school of visual art was the most literal. He imagined the school of visual arts, or as they called it, the school of plastic art,
它们蜿蜒、弯曲，延伸成广场和庭院。它们弯曲的屋顶和所有的拱顶使它们看起来栩栩如生，仿佛在跳舞。每一所学校都有一个清晰的故事要讲，带有非常刻意的象征意义。但波罗的视觉艺术学院是最直白的。他设想视觉艺术学院，或者他们称之为造型艺术学院，
as a building that would nurture art and artists, and help give rise to a uniquely post-revolution Cuban aesthetic. This school was going to give birth. So I tried to make this school of plastic art as the image of a goddess of fertility. So I put a lot of rest in the domes. No, really. The vaulted domes have these nipples on them.
是一座能够培育艺术和艺术家的建筑，并有助于催生一种独特的后革命古巴美学。这所学校将孕育生命。所以我试图把这所造型艺术学院塑造成生育女神的形象。不，真的。拱形圆顶上有这些乳头状的突起。
And there was a special fountain in the main piata. And in the piata, I placed a sculpture I did. Just like a fruit called papaya, that in Cuba has this sexual feminine connotation. Some higher ups found this pretty scandalous. Poro was told to turn the water in the fountain off. Yes, you have the breast, and here you have the papaya, which is a metaphor for what everybody knows in the Caribbean. But I think that it's wrong to overemphasize that.
主广场上有一个特殊的喷泉。在广场上，我放置了我做的一件雕塑。就像一种叫木瓜的水果，在古巴，它具有这种性感的女性内涵。一些高层觉得这很丢人。波罗被告知要关掉喷泉里的水。是的，你有乳房，这里有木瓜，这是加勒比地区众所周知的隐喻。但我认为过度强调这一点是错误的。
Because really, John Luma says that the school is a commentary on Cuba's past and future. As you're walking down those curved passageways, you can't see where you've been, and you can't see where you're going. In a way that was a metaphor for this new chapter in Cuba, this was a new adventure, this new revolution. The revolutionary spirit was the driving force of the design and the construction. The Catalan vault required a lot of labor, so there was this massive crew of young Cuban
因为约翰·卢米斯说，这所学校实际上是对古巴过去和未来的评论。当你走在那些弯曲的通道上时，你看不见你来过的地方，也看不见你要去的地方。在某种程度上，这是古巴新篇章的隐喻，这是一次新的冒险，这场新的革命。革命精神是设计和施工的驱动力。加泰罗尼亚拱顶需要大量劳动力，所以有一大批年轻的古巴
workers on the golf course making these structures. All the workers felt a real buy-in because they felt that they were building the school that their children could potentially go to, whereas previously they had no hope that their children would go to university or to an art school. And this endeavor was so exciting that the schools basically opened while they were still being built. At some point when construction began, they said, well, let's just use the space. The country club was already there with its meeting rooms and ballrooms, and of course
工人在高尔夫球场上建造这些结构。所有的工人都感到真正的投入，因为他们觉得他们正在建造一所他们的孩子将来可能就读的学校，而在此之前，他们根本不敢奢望自己的孩子能上大学或艺术学校。这项事业如此令人兴奋，以至于学校在还在建设中时就基本上开放了。在施工开始后的某个时候，他们说，好吧，我们就利用这个空间吧。乡村俱乐部已经有了会议室和宴会厅，当然
they had those manicured grounds on the beautiful weather. Ballerinas pirouetted on the putting green. Painter set up their canvases in the shade, violinists practiced in the forest. And students brought water and drinks and food for the construction workers and played drums to keep their spirits up. It was this beautiful, joyous undertaking, except when it wasn't.
他们有那些修剪整齐的场地和美丽的天气。芭蕾舞演员在果岭上旋转。画家在树荫下支起画布，小提琴手在森林里练习。学生们为建筑工人带来水、饮料和食物，并敲鼓来鼓舞士气。这是一项美丽、欢乐的事业，除了有时并非如此。
During that time and still today, it's difficult to talk about the negative aspects of the revolution. So people really focused on the joyous part and the optimism, you know, because that's what do you hold on to when you're in this land of paradox. Alessanamias co-produced a documentary about the Cuban art schools. In Cuba, at the same time, for example, as artists were having drum parties to finish the buildings while the mason's were working and it was very beautiful and fun and joyous.
在那段时间里，直到今天，谈论革命的负面方面都很困难。所以人们真的专注于欢乐的部分和乐观情绪，你知道，因为当你身处这个充满悖论的土地时，你只能坚持这些。阿丽莎·纳米斯联合制作了一部关于古巴艺术学校的纪录片。在古巴，与此同时，例如，当艺术家们在泥瓦匠工作时举行鼓乐派对来完成建筑时，这非常美丽、有趣且欢乐。
There were other students who were sent to labor camps because they were homosexual. Or religious, or in other ways, anti-revolutionary. And even before those agricultural labor camps opened in 1965, the anti-revolutionary students were expelled from the art schools. Ricardo Poro continued to give them classes in his home. Poro can feel that the values of the revolution were shifting, as he says in the documentary. I used to tell the other architects, don't lose your time, making small details. Try to do things fast because perhaps one day it's going to be stopped. After the missile crisis, after the Bay of Pigs, military defense was given a much higher
还有其他学生因为是同性恋而被送往劳改营。或者因为宗教信仰，或者以其他方式被视为反革命。甚至在1965年那些农业劳改营开放之前，反革命学生就被艺术学校开除了。里卡多·波罗继续在家里给他们上课。波罗能感觉到革命的价值观正在发生变化，正如他在纪录片中所说的那样。我过去常告诉其他建筑师，不要浪费时间做小细节。试着快点做，因为也许有一天它会被叫停。在导弹危机之后，在猪湾事件之后，军事防御被赋予了比创造世界上最美丽的艺术学校更高的
priority than, say, creating the most beautiful art schools in the world. So there was the money issue, but also generally generally, Cuba was starting to imitate the Soviet Union in more and more ways. I made a very individual architecture and they wanted Soviet architecture. The Soviet architecture was blocky, functional, uniform, one-size-fits-all, completely the opposite of the sensuous, organic vaults and curves of the art schools. There was an idea that the designs for the Cuban National Art Schools were extravagant for a socialist revolution that had to tighten its belt. And one of the earliest proponents of that argument was Roberto Segre.
优先级。所以存在资金问题，但总的来说，古巴开始在越来越多的方面模仿苏联。我做的是非常个人化的建筑，而他们想要苏联式的建筑。苏联建筑是方块状的、功能性的、统一的、千篇一律的，与艺术学校感性、有机的拱顶和曲线完全相反。有一种观点认为，古巴国家艺术学校的设计对于一个必须勒紧裤腰带的社会主义革命来说太奢侈了。而这一论点的最早支持者之一是罗伯托·塞格雷。
Roberto Segre was the architecture critic. Like really, he was the only one. He had tremendous influence. Segre was not a fan of the breasts and the papaya fountain, as Segre himself says in the film. No, I am not a game the sex. I like the sex with whom and not with architecture. These days, Segre admits that he was a bit harsh.
罗伯托·塞格雷是建筑评论家。真的，他是唯一的评论家。他有巨大的影响力。塞格雷不喜欢乳房和木瓜喷泉，正如塞格雷自己在电影中所说的那样。不，我不是反对性。我喜欢性，但不是在建筑中。如今，塞格雷承认他当时有点苛刻。
Now, Segre will say that he really didn't want to write those things, but he was under constraints by people higher up, mostly Antonio Quintana. Antonio Quintana was the last of a generation of established Cuban architects. All his contemporaries had fled during the revolution, and this left Quintana at the top of his field by default, and he wanted it to stay that way. Kintana clearly had a personal desire not to see Ricardo Poro continue to thrive as an architect in Cuba. The architect Kintana and the critic Roberto Segre helped turn favor against the schools. Workers were slowly reduced the amount of workers. Poro's buildings were far enough finished,
现在，塞格雷会说他真的不想写那些东西，但他受到上层人士的约束，主要是安东尼奥·金塔纳。安东尼奥·金塔纳是古巴老一代建筑师中的最后一位。他的同代人在革命期间都逃跑了，这使得金塔纳默认成为了该领域的顶尖人物，他希望保持这种状态。金塔纳显然有一种个人愿望，不希望看到里卡多·波罗继续作为一名建筑师在古巴蓬勃发展。建筑师金塔纳和评论家罗伯托·塞格雷帮助扭转了对学校的看法。工人们被慢慢减少。波罗的建筑已经完成得足够多了，
so they were really able to be brought to the finish line or very very very close. But the schools designed by the other two architects were not so lucky. The theater school was only 30 percent complete. The music school was also unfinished but had a few usable rooms. The most unfinished was the ballet school, which didn't have floorboards or glass on the windows. All the materials were there and it could have been finished in like 15 days. And the lead of the Cuban ballet, Alicia Lonso, who's a very famous Cuban ballerina, she visited the site.
所以它们确实能够被带到终点线，或者非常非常接近。但其他两位建筑师设计的学校就没有那么幸运了。戏剧学校只完成了30%。音乐学校也未完工，但有几个可用的房间。最未完工的是芭蕾舞学校，它没有地板，窗户上也没有玻璃。所有的材料都在那里，本来可以在15天左右完成。古巴芭蕾舞团的负责人，非常著名的古巴芭蕾舞演员艾丽西亚·阿隆索，她参观了现场。
And she says, I don't like it. No more ballet here. And that was that. The Cuban ballet opted for a much more centrally located studio. And in July of 1965, the schools were just declared finished in all their varying states of completion. They had an opening, declared them open, and they were used in the state that they were. Even the unfinished ballet school was used very briefly, as a Russian circus school.
她说，我不喜欢它。这里不再有芭蕾舞了。事情就是这样。古巴芭蕾舞团选择了位置更中心的工作室。1965年7月，这些学校在各种不同的完工状态下被宣布完工。他们举行了开幕式，宣布它们开放，并以当时的状态投入使用。即使是未完工的芭蕾舞学校也被短暂地用作俄罗斯马戏学校。
The architects were scattered to different jobs within the Ministry of Construction. Ricardo Poro started working directly under Antonio Quintana, that last of the old guard architects, Poro's nemesis. Quintana gave him very demeaning jobs. He gave him the job to design a cage for an eagle in the zoo. Oh my God. I couldn't work anymore in my architecture,
建筑师们被分散到建设部的不同工作中。里卡多·波罗开始直接在安东尼奥·金塔纳手下工作，那是老派建筑师的最后一位，波罗的宿敌。金塔纳给了他非常贬低的工作。他让他设计一个动物园里的鹰笼。天哪。我不能再从事我的建筑工作了，
or I had to do all four things as they were doing. And I decided to lift Cuba. In 1966, Poro left Cuba and moved to Paris. And as for the schools themselves, the crazy thing is that they never closed. Even during some horrible spells in Cuba's history, when entire families were squatting in the rundown parts of the schools and ransacking them for materials, classes have always continued.
或者我必须像他们一样做所有四件事。我决定离开古巴。1966年，波罗离开古巴移居巴黎。至于学校本身，疯狂的是它们从未关闭。即使在古巴历史上一些可怕的时期，当整个家庭在学校破旧的部分非法居住并为了材料而洗劫它们时，课程也一直在继续。
Well, except for the ballet school where the classes never quite started, but the other four art schools continued to be among the finest in the world. Although they are not as big as they were meant to be, and they're pretty rundown in some parts. It floods. Like the first time I went there, there was a guy playing drums, but I think there was like a foot of water in the building. Today the schools are known as ISA, Issa. Issa, what it's called now. The Institute Superior de Arte. So no one's going to come yell at us? the institute superior, the arte.
嗯，除了芭蕾舞学校，那里的课程从未真正开始，但其他四所艺术学校继续成为世界上最好的艺术学校之一。虽然它们没有预想的那么大，而且在某些部分相当破旧。它会淹水。就像我第一次去那里时，有一个人在打鼓，但我认为建筑里有一英尺深的水。今天，这些学校被称为ISA，伊萨。伊萨，这就是它现在的名字。高等艺术学院。所以没人会来对我们大喊大叫？高等艺术学院。
So no one's going to come yell at us? Especially on the rain nobody's going to come. The schools with students have guards of course, but Felipe del Zidas showed every the abandoned ballet school. I have come many times and haven't seen any security guard, which is a problem because now that is graffiti and things happening there that shouldn't be happening. Sometimes you want the security to be there. Felipe is a multimedia artist who once studied at the theater school.
所以没人会来对我们大喊大叫？特别是在雨中，没人会来。有学生的学校当然有警卫，但费利佩·德尔·西达斯展示了废弃的芭蕾舞学校。我来过很多次，没见过任何保安，这是一个问题，因为现在那里有涂鸦和不该发生的事情发生。有时你希望有安保人员在那里。费利佩是一位多媒体艺术家，曾经在戏剧学校学习。
Back then, the unfinished ballet school was a mysterious ruin. Because when I was totally here in the 80s, the whole thing here was a jungle. Students would go there and party and stuff. To hang out if you have a girlfriend or a date, it was a great place to roam. He didn't know the story of the buildings. No one really did. The story of this school was a somehow like a taboo. It was never spoken, never discussed. It was somehow like a taboo. It was never spoken, never discussed. It was, there was like a secrecy about it. But then John Lumis, who we've been talking to throughout this episode,
那时，未完工的芭蕾舞学校是一片神秘的废墟。因为当我在80年代来到这里时，整个地方都是丛林。学生们会去那里聚会之类的。如果你有女朋友或约会对象，这是一个闲逛的好地方。他不知道这些建筑的故事。没人真正知道。这所学校的故事在某种程度上是一种禁忌。它从未被谈论，从未被讨论。它在某种程度上是一种禁忌。它从未被谈论，从未被讨论。它，有一种关于它的秘密。但后来约翰·卢米斯，也就是我们在这一集中一直交谈的人，
published his book about the schools called Revolution of Forms. Revolution of Forms came out in March of 1999. And through Revolution of Forms, Felipe finally learned the story of this place where he had studied for five years. This is really shameful, and that they are not taking care of their things. This is something that was done with a lot of love and with a lot of care.
出版了他的关于这些学校的书，名为《形式的革命》。《形式的革命》于1999年3月出版。通过《形式的革命》，费利佩终于了解了他学习了五年的这个地方的故事。这真的很可耻，他们没有照顾好自己的东西。这是用很多爱和很多关心完成的事情。
And it's something that only belonged to Cuba, y es algo que no solo es lo que es lo que es lo que es lo que es lo que es la cultura humana, la cultura humana. Y Felipe, no era la única persona inspirada por Luma. Pero yo tengo esperanza que ustedes me defiendan y defiendan la idea de que este escuela superior the idea that this school is higher than the one in the 40th grade. That is Fidel Castro in 1999 saying, this school will get done. This national art school that we imagined will get built. Okay, we can't say that John Luma single-handedly convinced Fidel Castro to take action on the art schools.
这是唯一属于古巴的东西，它不仅是人类文化的一部分。费利佩并不是唯一一个被卢米斯启发的人。但我希望你们能捍卫我，捍卫这所高等艺术学院比40年级那所更好的想法。那是1999年的菲德尔·卡斯特罗在说，这所学校会完成的。我们设想的这所国家艺术学校将会建成。好吧，我们不能说约翰·卢米斯单枪匹马地说服了菲德尔·卡斯特罗对艺术学校采取行动。
But the year revolution of forms came out, Fidel Castro publicly committed to restoring them. All three architects reunited in Havana and met with high-level government officials to plan the restoration. But this project was abandoned in the wake of the financial crisis in 2000. For now, the schools remain in various states of completion. But even in their current disrepair, the architecture speaks for itself. This view is...
但在《形式的革命》出版的那一年，菲德尔·卡斯特罗公开承诺修复它们。三位建筑师在哈瓦那重聚，并与政府高级官员会面，计划修复工作。但这个项目在2000年金融危机后被搁置了。目前，这些学校仍处于各种不同的完工状态。但即使在目前的破败中，建筑本身也会说话。这个景色是……
Something else. Something else. Look at my skin. Who's pumps? Yeah, this is for to look at something. Mm. The schools of Issa don't look like any other buildings in the world. They are Cuban.
别的东西。别的东西。看看我的皮肤。什么泵？是的，这是为了看东西。嗯。伊萨的学校看起来不像世界上任何其他建筑。它们是古巴的。
They are the product, victim, and symbol of a revolution. To really understand the majesty of these schools, including some fascinating parts of the story that just don't translate to radio, watch the beautiful documentary, Unfinished Spaces, by Alyssa Namius and Ben Murray. It's rentable on iTunes, but you can find out all about it at UnfinishedSpaces.com. You've also been listening to the film Soundtrack throughout this episode, which was composed by Giancarlo Volcano. Special thanks, of course, to John Lomis, author of Revolution of Forms. I was accused in Cuba of being an employee of the CIA and writing this book to embarrass Cuba,
它们是一场革命的产物、受害者和象征。要真正理解这些学校的宏伟，包括故事中一些无法翻译成广播的迷人部分，请观看阿丽莎·纳米斯和本·默里拍摄的美丽纪录片《未完成的空间》。它可以在iTunes上租借，但你可以在UnfinishedSpaces.com上了解所有相关信息。在这一集中，你一直在听电影原声带，它是由吉安卡洛·沃尔卡诺创作的。当然，特别感谢《形式的革命》的作者约翰·卢米斯。我在古巴被指控是中央情报局的雇员，写这本书是为了让古巴难堪，
and that's not all. I don't think it embarrasses Cuba. I hope not. Along with Jacob Reems, Jill Hamburg, Albert Lopez, Dorothea Troublemen, and Charles Coppola. I am the producer and the broadest of Kubanikan, the new Cuban opera. The opera about the Cuban art schools just premiered at the art schools. As far as we know, the last full Cuban opera written in Cuba and performed in Cuba was over 50 years ago. It sounds like this. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Avery Truffleman with Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars.
这还不是全部。我不认为它让古巴难堪。我希望没有。与雅各布·里姆斯、吉尔·汉堡、阿尔伯特·洛佩兹、多萝西娅·特鲁布曼和查尔斯·科波拉一起。我是《古巴尼坎》的制片人和广播员，这是一部新的古巴歌剧。关于古巴艺术学校的歌剧刚刚在艺术学校首演。据我们所知，最后一部在古巴创作并在古巴演出的完整古巴歌剧是50多年前的事了。听起来是这样的。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。
We are a project of 91.7 KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxan. The East Bay's premiere, architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can keep up with all the comings and goings of 99% invisible on Twitter, Facebook, Tumblr, Instagram and Spotify and you can always catch up with us at our place at 99pi.org. RX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在Arxan的办公室制作。东湾首屈一指的建筑和室内设计公司，位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心。你可以在Twitter、Facebook、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上关注《99%隐形》的所有动态，你也可以随时在我们的网站99pi.org上了解我们。RX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。